hi
hi ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
welcome back to the gen swimming podcast
this is brought to you by thredup
we just got back from girls summer camp
yeah it was great it was really fun
summer
i bruised my knee a couple times i
wanted a friendship bracelet
oh yeah thread up um guys
right now go to t-h-r-e-d-u-p dot com
slash jenna julian get an extra 30
off your first order at thredup what is
thredup it is uh
a place where you can get uh amazing
awesome clothes at up to 90
discounted price it's the largest online
thrift store
and you can check it out right now with
a link down below get an extra 30
off with our code also guys farmer's dog
if you want your dogs
to love meal time and also get the most
out of their food
with a healthier diet that they enjoy go
to farmer's dog
it is uh it is awesome our dogs enjoy it
they love it
they're actually kind of fiends for it
it's a little scary uh go to
farmersdog.com
thefarmersdog.com
t-h-e-f-a-r-m-e-r-s-d-o-g
dot com slash jen and julian that's at
the in front of it to get started uh
you get 50 off your first two weeks with
that url
i think your dog will like it so
now we're not talking to you we're
talking your dog you're welcome
hope you enjoy wolf
that's amazing you can talk to people's
dogs through the podcast really
yeah i have a special ability i point
and dogs know where i'm pointing to
okay why don't you show us buddy
she looked that way surely she thought
about it oh
really yeah oh that's incredible
what are you smelling i don't know the
weather
sorry if we're in a weird mood uh we're
not in a weird mood
we're great but we haven't drank any
caffeine in like three days
you ever just like cycle off caffeine
for a little while
[Music]
it's really helpful for those of you
that like caffeine it's really helpful
to cycle off caffeine for a little bit
i'm cycling off for good
oh okay i'm never touching this stuff
again good for you
i don't know i just uh i made the
decision the other day and jenna joined
along with me it was really great
if you do it i'd do it it's much easier
to do with a pal that's for sure
and that's what we are if not anything
we're just pals right
yeah well i feel like whenever we get to
the point where you need that like
late afternoon sort of like caffeine
then i'm like oh we should slow this
down because then i'm [ __ ]
wired at like three in the morning and i
can't sleep
yeah it was like like wiggly i don't
know i'm i'm always like the biggest
proponent of like let's [ __ ] drink
caffeine all the time
like we're on internet schedule we don't
have to like you know no rules
and that's all fun and good until like
you said in the evening you're drinking
caffeine
for something you're doing even like for
us every stream
and then you get into bed at night and
you're just like
terribly awake and even when you do
sleep it's not good sleep
no i was waking up tired wiggle sleep
waking up a zombie
drinking caffeine to become just like a
baseline normal human
so i decided uh you know what let's
[ __ ] let's give it a go
so today is day three of zero caffeine
day one was brutal i didn't have a hard
time
no i'm explaining my experience oh okay
you go next
okay day one well
here's what happened day one i worked
out which probably wasn't smart
because my trainer we've been doing like
facetime workouts and he
made me do circuit training and he knew
i was on no caffeine and he still did it
to me like that
he's a sick he's a sick [ __ ] his name
and address will be in the description
below no um yeah so we did a workout and
that's when i started to get a little
bit of a headache
when i was getting my blood pump in and
my heart rate went up a little bit of
headache
and um then i streamed for like five and
a half six hours
which was kind of tough uh usually
that's an easy stream i'm like i'm
breezing through it
especially if the game's fun no problem
but
like halfway through i started to get
like a pounding headache and i just like
pushed through a push through push
through and by the end of stream i
turned it off and i had to lay down
because my head hurt so bad
um but day three i have to say i have
not had a headache yet i feel great
i woke up with probably the most energy
yet
uh this is not urine i know you might
have thought this was your because it's
the color no one thought that was urine
julian
it's gatorade just clearing it up babe
i don't want anyone starting rumors oh
my god um
yeah so i don't know we're is that yeah
we're a little loopy but i feel
honestly better every day you feel
vibing i feel you
i feel vibrant oh chick you revived i'm
vibing oh he's driving
i'm vibing are you vibing yeah
did you see that clip of uh where does
he go by now puff daddy
p diddy love what's he go by now
i don't know what he goes by what's the
clip it's a clip of him in the car and
he's like
oh [ __ ] oh i was thinking about
vibrating lower today i really was
but [ __ ] that i'ma vibrate higher have
you seen that
oh man i love that is that a new is that
new
or is that an old video you know i'm not
home centered i want to vibrate higher
that's like how i feel every day and
like you know i feel like i could
vibrate lower today but you know what
[ __ ] that i'm gonna vibrate higher
when given the choice between lower and
higher which do you vibrate
well um i
i didn't actually plan on doing this but
i'm gonna [ __ ] do it
i asked on our instagram stories for
some
podcast suggestions and
a lot of them were pretty good a lot of
them were kind of like you know based
off of stuff we've done in the past
but holy [ __ ] some of them were really
bad
um and i just want to shout those out
someone said go someone said go on cold
ones i love that
because it's like it implies that you
just walk through a magical door onto
someone else's content
and you're just there so thank you for
that
idea
uh someone said what's the best vegan
gluten-free tortilla chip
my answer is they're all gluten-free and
vegan pretty much
and also that's not a podcast they're
just chips
i hope you find the chips you're looking
for yeah i don't know there's a lot i
can go through more what do you what do
you have to show us here i got it for
you i got it it's on his instagram
[Music]
right that is a new video
i was about to vibrate lower careful
that you don't vibrate lower guys it's
it happens when you're not paying
attention it does
sometimes i feel the temptation to
vibrate lower but then i decide i would
like to vibrate higher
why did you just look at me like that
julian i don't know why can't i
aside from the caffeine thing i'm also
losing it just from
feeling like i'm in the truman show you
know
yeah it's a little bit like eerie these
days
so things start to blend together and
days start to feel the same and you
start talking to the walls
okay no what no i talk to the walls
you can't say no about that what do you
say to the walls between me and the
walls
they will never tell you
what were you gonna say sweetheart for
the podcast today we were just gonna
talk to some people oh yeah we're going
to time our loved ones we're going to
facetime some loved ones it's not a
comprehensive list of all the people
that we love but this is a list of the
people that we have
texted and asked permission to facetime
today
we have yeah they've all signed uh
waivers
yeah for sure by by responding to our
text saying yeah i'll facetime you
that's the waiver
who are we calling well we're gonna call
my mom
it's too early to call your mom we told
her to call her in 15 minutes
we got to kill 15 minutes you can call
will
chris and shannon mm-hmm exciting
yeah we can call chris and shim
still early for them what time did you
tell them i told them all it's gonna be
at the same time
julian i'm not a planner i don't know
let's just call chris
oh my god all right all right um i'm
gonna try to record the call
video and then we'll put it up here or
something
yeah we have a green screen it's sort of
this is a green screen something
that we're all going through is keeping
in contact with our loved ones julian
so it would be really fun to talk to our
friends
and family today that's a good idea
that's a good idea yeah did you just
think of that
right now off the cuff oh my god oh i
got to record
record i was thinking about vibrating
lower but i'm going to vibrate higher
oh what up
hi how are you guys doing
how are you dude we're good we're just
we're just making content over here you
know sam
actually i'm watching content what are
you watching
the midnight gospel is it good
yeah it's from the creator of adventure
time it's on netflix it's actually
really funny and cool
i'm interested tell me what it's about
it's a cartoon about a guy who visits
different worlds it's like vr chat kind
of actually wait can i see your guys's
new tattoos
sure mine's kind of like in a weird spot
mommy
has pants on they gave stick they did
stick and poke tattoos what is this
sticking poke tattoo
um explain it first
it's inking a needle in a very sterile
environment
with your own hands you take you take a
little a little needle and you poke your
leg a bunch and then you get something
like this
oh that's dope what's his name
i only did my fingers oh you do those
dots so
pretty that's so cool yeah she's like a
cool girl she's like a tumblr girl now
all right
all right whatever hey chris you know
what shirt i'm wearing dude
i need you sure same same oh nice
they're all matching jenny
oh no oh no i didn't get the memo
[Music]
did you take a shower you look like you
smell good yeah i just did actually
oh
[Laughter]
we're good we're um we're just i don't
know we're just kind of losing it a
little bit we're not drinking caffeine
right now so we're drinking gatorade
do you like movies yeah they're they're
okay sometimes
we watch them the mask of zorro last
night
what'd you watch zorro whoa
what a classic yeah zoro dude
[Laughter]
he does though there's no lie we watch
he does we watched all the new hobbits
was it good
well they're not new they're kind of new
i didn't i forgot they existed for like
a whole poor
portion of time they're cool
i heard you talking about it on stream
you said you didn't like it
so i i didn't think so i thought i
didn't like it and then i watched them
and i was like that's like a fun movie
that's cool how many are there i don't
even know there was multiple is that bad
oh there's three of them yeah i only saw
one of them were they also like four
hours each
no it was three and a half out two and a
half hours no no three
three and then like two and a half no
it's not bad
yeah but might uh might try this new
minecraft uh
mod soon it's a little bit they re built
they remade more of the rings
like middle earth and it takes you six
hours to get from the shire to mordor oh
my god
that's so dope actually is that kind of
cool that sounds fun yeah
like an adventure you know yeah six
hours a short little stream
oh she just she just she she pushed her
body weight onto my chest when she sat
back down
this is our apartment nice looks good
thanks we uh we're fine we're alone for
the first time in two months
your pals who are quarantined with you
are not there
yeah so sarah went back to work and mike
had to go home because his dad
started going back to work so he wanted
to be safe so now it's just us
nice you guys are going to drive each
other nuts now huh
that's that's that's annoying hey chris
nice
wait you paid his nails what the hell
you never asked me
you do yours in like four seconds i do
him so fast i think i think he did his
own
no sorry oh i thought you did your own
whatever
yeah we're good we're just um i don't
know kind of just doing the same thing
all the time
you should do some stick and pokes jenny
you want a second poke
how about like a whole big one across
your back yeah whole big one
you guys should stick a poke and you
should also do stick and poke tattoos
wait you have a lot of supplies yeah way
too many
the needles we can send you a little
care package maybe i got all the
different colors
is it hard is it hard to do a stick and
poke tattoo
no no it's actually it's really easy but
it's like it's kind of
no one taught me what to do so i was i
was very dumb at first you have to like
hit the same spot
you trace your what you're going to do
you need to hit the same spot like five
times
so you have to do like this hold on
sorry
that's a good demonstration can you
record yourself doing that so i know
what to do later
yeah i'll send you a video of me just
doing that okay um
but yeah i the worst part was i had the
whole tracing on my leg and then i
started drawing
like sick and poking and then i went to
like wipe away the ink just to see what
it looked like
and got rid of the whole drawing too so
then i had to like just guess
what it looks like it came out pretty
good though
yeah i'm happy with it it's like it's
like it's like a cool little memory from
being quarantined i miss you guys
sitting right here and actually being on
the podcast
oh that's nice look at those hands you
guys hold them
oh i should wish the chance should be
there why just me i don't know because
you sat there i'd go on the other side
it
chris would stand behind the camera he
would just be our camera guy and action
and action so that this is being
released on monday
yeah in two days happy monday happy
monday happy monday
thank you guys for taking the call i
appreciate it thank you for helping us
make content we need it
of course you know yesterday was so fun
pubg
[Laughter]
it went great we got a lot of wins pubg
was a good time
you guys enjoyed the uh throwback with
the old email sounds crazy
good luck on your turnips everybody i
don't know what that means
it's an animal crosstalk oh got it okay
well we'll see you guys
later i guess oh i hope you uh call more
people that are that are just as just as
cool
bye bye oh
i love our friends i miss them so much
dude
is that what i mean we all the thing is
like we always miss them
though even when we're able to travel
because
they're they live across the world from
us
but we especially miss them right now
because actually those two
are chris and chad if you don't know who
they are they're our best friends they
live in jersey and they've been on the
podcast a couple times
and they've been with us you know in
content so you've seen them
uh likely but they were supposed to be
here in april i was supposed to have
them over for my birthday we were
supposed to have a whole big thing
and uh obviously we cancelled so we
especially miss them right now
i just like having them around they're
good energy
shan is an aries shannon is an aries
cheers to her
sad yeah it is you talk to somebody that
you know is in your family or friends
and it's so happy for a minute and then
when you're done talking to them you're
like
you just want to cry
you know kermit probably feels that
about breakfast because i feed him the
farmer's dog every day in the morning
and he gets so excited and then as soon
as it's over he just wants to cry and in
fact he does cry
that's how good farmer's dog is when
kermit is done eating it he cries
i want more if you're curious about
farmer's dog
i can't encourage you enough to try it
out
it is a really really great service they
provide human grade and people tested
recipes developed by board certified
vet nutritionists so your dog is getting
the right stuff in their food okay it's
not just
any old kibble that you're getting from
you know your local pet store this is
like
constructed with health
of your pet in mind and also if you have
a piggy eater i guarantee you
farmer's dog will help solve that
problem marbles used to not eat any food
there was like this period where he just
didn't like food and we didn't know what
to do
and then we tried farmer's dog and now
he runs faster than
the the greyhounds he breaks the sound
barrier
he breaks the sound barrier on his way
to the meal there is a
sonic boom that happens in the kitchen
i'm serious though his tiny legs move at
such a fast speed
because he knows we're about to feed him
farmer's dog uh
so all you have to do is you go to
thefarmersdog.com you fill out
a little questionnaire about your pet um
what they like to eat what they don't
like to eat what their eating schedule
is eating habits
what type of dog how big they are maybe
if their dog if you know if your pet
needs to put on some weight or lose some
weight you can
include that and they will calculate the
exact amount of calories
that your dog will need in a meal
and they'll send you a box of
meals ready to go and individual
packages it's super easy to feed them
uh we love it i think you should try it
check it out go to thefarmersdog.com and
get 50 off your first two weeks
when you use that url check it out
also guys uh thredup it is
the world's largest online thrift store
it gives you
up to 90 off estimated retail price you
can filter by your size
to find the stuff that fits you right
away you can search shop
and check out instantly and you got some
new stuff on the way you can shop from
nike about around five dollars j
crew starting at six dollars you can
shop the brands you like but for prices
you love
uh it is a really really cool service
especially with right now if you want to
you know do some thrifting it's hard to
do but you can do it with thread up from
the comfort of your couch
on your laptop or even on your phone so
check it out go to threadup.com
jenna julian you sign up now to get 90
off estimated retail price of top name
brand
and designer clothes and you get an
extra 30 off when you use our url so
not only are you getting the discounted
thrift clothes
price from thredup you're getting an
extra 30 off of your order
because you came to our podcast and you
listened
to us talk about sponsors and we
appreciate you for doing that so
enjoy the discount check the link down
below
thank you sponsors sponsors
calling your mom or you want me to do it
well you want to do it on your phone so
then all the
files are in the same place
that's true the files are in the
computer the files are
in the you have two minutes though
i'll call will then no
your mom yeah well she you just said uh
for
11 45. okay well it's 11 43.
so i'm gonna go ahead and uh it's 11 44.
roll the dice here
oh no
i'm drinking gay right
hold it over the mic if you can so her
audio gets picked up
like this there you go
we got debbie on the line no we don't
she's ignoring us oh
look who it is
hello and welcome to my home oh
[ __ ] what are you doing
well i'm going out to do a little
gardening so i have a gardening hairdo
oh a gardening hairdo ah yes
a nice sophisticated style for the
garden
well you know because i won't show you
the gardening
hat but well but for why not you will
you not
we need to see the gardening hat we
demand the gardening hat
okay you asked for it
but for please show us the gardening hat
oh
[ __ ] it up [ __ ] it up
nice it looks real good what kind of
shirt you working with today
oh you got a sushi shirt hold on now do
you think i would wear the sushi shirt
get to the garden
oh you know what that's a good call you
need
to preserve smithsonian oh it's going to
the smithsonian
but in a surprise appearance
wait i gotta put this down in a surprise
appearance
oh
yeah you wear them once they fit and
then you wear them again
and then they're all stretched out
that's how a lot of jeans are
i think i need a fashion intervention no
i don't think so at all i think you're
killing it
you're killing it those jeans are so
dope where'd you get them thread up
sorry cut are you wearing open-toed
shoes into the garden what happens if
you damage your footsie
in a gardening accident wait let me i
want to see i want to see the kicks
oh wait i gotta go back to the other
room um okay yeah because
well no i'm these are in the house um
in the house zories what
flip-flops oh flip-flops
yeah when i was a kid we called him zory
so
was that like a brand or did you always
just genuinely not know how to speak
honestly i think it was something we
made
if there's other new englanders on your
on your stream they will say oh yeah we
could just like glory
new landers new englanders
new englanders oh i think you said neil
in news because she really forgot how to
speak
new island is with us yeah yeah zoilies
what do you call them new landers are a
special country that i come from
it's new land new land what's the
capital of new orleans zoyland
no the capital of norland is zorri's
thank you
please don't make fun of don't make fun
of the place where i was born
so sorry yeah i mean you know
don't be toxic now
okay i won't don't be toxic so i got
these
no i i have other shoes that i wear into
the garden but
um
but here they are i'll show you here
they are
oh nice yeah
and there's the garden out there needs a
lot of work beautiful
that sounds like fun i want to work on
the garden right now
yeah we can go outside and work on it oh
okay
a little garden is good because it gives
you a little bit of work keep coughing
like that
can you see the grapevine no i can't
really see the grapevine but
oh wait yeah oh i'm sorry you have the
screen in front of it
oh look who it is making it making her
debut appearance in the garden
it's guilty is it gilded
is she eating something oh no oh no
no see the see the grapevine right there
oh it's pretty
it goes around yeah there's the chives
want me to send you some chives
yes please put them in the mail i'll get
them
and put them in an envelope yeah put
them in the envelope please and then
wrap that in a ziploc bag and then wrap
that in tin foil and put a stamp on it
please
just put the just put the stamps
directly on the tribes and send them
yeah please your garden is so lovely
well it was so lovely of you to come
from my house
it's so nice did you want to see my
artwork
yes we want to see your artwork okay
well here's can you wear your gardening
hairdo to your
grandchild art gallery show
here's the artwork from the grandchild
valentine's day card
just so sweet here's an inspirational
message
to come home to yourself may all that is
unforgiving in you be released
may your fears yield their deepest
tranquilities may all that is
unlived in you blossom into a future
something graced with love oh i like
that that's nice
in other words just do you buddy take us
to the art gallery
so awesome
i can't pretend that i haven't seen this
before because i have seen this before
but
mom your art is so cool this was
unfinished
here's some uh here's some little uh
here's some little postcard sized
collages
oh i like those and here's the drawing
that i did with clara and henry keep the
phone upright
with the kids my grandkids and they were
doing it nicely and i was doing it like
a wild person wow a wild
person so there's nice and little
and calm and small and mine looks
gigantic and
beast-like mom julian says you got to
turn the phone there you go
i'm sorry nothing you're good it's good
now
no oh no julian says keep the phone
upright oh keep the phone upright oh
sorry
there we go oh sorry oh so oh sorry
oh sorry
so cool this is a political one
this is a political one
i haven't seen any of that before it's
so cool debbie this one is not political
this one's
just do it just do it
just do it and stop telling me why you
can't do it
because i don't i care but i don't care
just do it
oops i can't really make that thing oh
okay that's the house tour thank you for
the house tour
sing we love your art we love you garden
what a woman look at it go i'm telling
you i'm just
like so blessed she is just a little
debbie in a big world
i was so excited she had grapes she had
fresh grapes
it was amazing
i can't wait and what am i gonna do
about blueberries because we usually go
blueberry picking here
[Music]
i'm sorry maybe you could i don't know
sneak over there sneak over there on
your zories a new zorries
oh god i'm never gonna hear the end of
that right uh hi
my name is zory i'm wearing zory's and
i'm from new orleans
oh yeah from new land yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm from new orleans yeah i forgot
that
it's right between newfoundland and new
orleans
and ships and noise is in the middle of
it
in new orleans is ships and noises is
the port town of new island
amazing and
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
she's trying to teach me how to play
backgammon i'm a very poor student
she's so good at it your dog
yeah she's so good at it and um i'm i'm
just trying to learn and she's such an
impatient teacher like make one mistake
and she's like oh [ __ ]
hey what a sophisticated animal
i'm not kidding you your dog's not that
smart that's my friend's
sunset she's just doing all trying to
get guilty to do these tricks
and he and you know she would she was
like doing that
and he's like your duck's not that smart
yeah
he didn't have to roast her like well
did he know your dog was teaching you
back hammond so
it jokes on that kid she is smart she
just doesn't want to
do your [ __ ] yeah i mean right
yeah so hey
webby thank you for being a part of the
podcast yeah amazing thank you so much
what a great time
i can't wait till you're back here in
person
me either what an incredible sushi shirt
what an appearance you know it had to
make it had
had to come out sometime and i'm glad if
it had to come back to me from the
smithsonian
this isn't the real sushi shirt this is
as facsimile
right yeah they sell it at the gift shop
right right you have to keep the
original
but um but you know if it had to come
back and make a debut
i think this is the perfect day it's a
great it's beautiful
great day well we love you so much
i'm hoping that uh that you are everyone
is safe
and well and i love you and i'm sending
my
big arms around you right now
love you love you
[Music]
hi kerm no no no that doesn't mean the
podcast is over
she's a legend amongst legends
a legend right worm you know how you say
every time you put a wig on me i
indulge in myself that's the same with
your mom and her sushi shirt
she puts it on and she just she comes
she becomes a different
debbie she becomes the lady from new
orleans
that's it it's her alter ego yeah we
should go visit new orleans someday
new orleans what is it underneath new
england you go underneath
yeah that's where it is new island the
the upside down of new england
all right i'm gonna call will now will
sheahan y'all
all right are you enjoying this it's fun
right
fun i mean i am because i'm selfish
me too i'm selfish too it's a great time
where's bobby i don't know is he not up
here
bobby left peach girl hi
give me the bob okay bobby wants to say
hi to will
dude oh we're getting the show on we're
getting the show
come here he's giving us a karate show
[ __ ] he tied his imaginary belt
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] look at those blocks damn
oh [ __ ] oh he's walking
who are you vlogging
look who's here to see you hold on i
gotta connect my earbuds
bobby
that was a hell of a karate show i
usually get those on my birthday
right what what's what a special
occasion it's been an honor we got a
full karate show
and we're paused can you see me
no i'm trying to connect my airpods oh
no
microphone sounds better your microphone
sounds better
check one two test tests okay that
should sound a little better
there we go yay my brain isn't turned on
is that okay
yeah mine's not turned on either mine's
off
mine's in sleep moment does this work
what the hell wait your brain's in sleep
mode
yeah oh my brain's in airplane mode i'm
surprised it didn't fly away
wait are you the pilot or the or the
passenger or the plane
yes
[Laughter]
guess who we just facetimed and guess
who was wearing a sushi shirt
your mom yeah yeah she was wearing the
sushi shirt but she said
it was a replica because the originals
in the smithsonian
i still gotta make a i gotta plan my
trip to go see that relic
oh my gosh yeah that's really special
what uh what are you guys doing on
podcast we are just
this we are facetiming we facetime chris
and chan and we facetime debbie and she
gave us a garden tour
[Music]
and told us that her dog was teaching
her backhand
it's a lie that's not true well jenna
thinks it's a lie but i take everything
debbie says at face value
i believe she's always telling the truth
well
yeah um yeah
i don't know we're just i feel like this
is like having guests right
yeah what are you doing well
i am sitting in my office drinking
coffee
um and trying to wake up
and today we were trying to re
fill our pool balance the chemicals
water the plant sorry my dad called i
had to decline
no no we're good we're good okay yeah we
were just like doing stuff outside like
tours and stuff and now i'm chilling
is it super hot over there or no it's
pretty hot yeah it's gonna get that's
why we're like scrambling to fix our
pool
because we know we're gonna want to use
it soon so
but yeah you did it you you guys emptied
the whole thing out right
what do you want to tour
dude i don't know of what though garden
toys
is there a garden or a pool tour or a
fin tour fin tour
i'll take a fin tour any day show us his
ears
and his hands he looks like he put on
uh gel this morning because
we monica washed him so he's all spiky
[Laughter]
hi finn hi bud
[Laughter]
finn is he picking your nose
spanky boy finn are you on the podcast
do you want to be on the podcast
what a good boy he's the goodest boy
okay that was the first tour what other
tour do you want bull tour
either pool or chips we're going on a
worldwide tour
oh [ __ ]
y'all come inside come on
all right
whoa wait you actually emptied it and
refilling it that's crazy oh
holy [ __ ] how do you empty a pool
you get a straw it's a submersible pump
you have to like pump that water there's
like a drain in the front
it's pretty easy it just takes time yeah
and now you're refilling it now we're
refilling it and we'll put chemicals in
it
but it looks like crystal clear poison
chemicals
yum chemicals
next tour damn we got three tours three
tours
world tour mr worldwide
oh oh
garden oh my god i love your garden dude
we got the lettuce what is that what are
we looking at
all right here we go we got
carrots whoa yum
we got onions
damn couple of onions
more carrots yes
carrots nicer good more onions
when do you know more
we got some little jalapenos
a jalapeno what else do we have
look at these little guys oh those look
good yeah those look nice
this is a tomato
tomato we just put that in and then
cucumber
dude absolutely baby carrots baby
is carrots this is salad this time yet
that was full the last time i saw it
that had like a bunch of lettuce
and then the zucchini squash
that's kind of it i mean there's beans
there but they're still super small
that's awesome
that was a great garden tour well thank
you for that he's such a gardener
he's a gardener he's a gardener
he's running he's running he's running
back to the fen tour
that's it
[Laughter]
oh is he chasing you
flowers oh flower tour nice dude
dude i feel like i'm outside in your
backyard right now this is magical
what kind of flowers things be blooming
what is that this is a
lentil i think it's called oh it's so
pretty
i got these cute things that are coming
out of these
desert beasts desert beasts
but they're nice
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] okay
well thank you for the five tours the
worldwide tour of tours
i wish we could get the podcast yeah
dude thank you you talked to i said
hello
dude tell bobby i said hello everyone
this is where you're sitting right here
this is right hand
it's right here wait
perfect thanks for having me
we love you later bye
oh my heart mm-hmm
well it's just the best well it's the
best his yard is crazy
he he has like so much effort energy
into that garden that garden is so
incredible dude
he if you guys are like man i wish he
would like have a whole youtube channel
on it because i feel like
he's so good at like teaching too yeah
um but he has all these beds out there
with the cages on them so they don't get
eaten up
and he has the watering system built in
and it's similar to our neighbors they
have a really similar setup but it's
just like really [ __ ] cool
it's growing all his own food right now
i mean all the produce yeah
well i don't know i don't know if this
is fun to watch but i hope it was
i had a good time i had a really good
time facing our friends i feel like uh
this is like like we said this is our
way of kind of like interacting with our
friends like we would have guests on the
podcast but we can't yeah so well maybe
sometime we'll
reach out to somebody we haven't had on
the podcast and maybe we can
skype them in or uh facetime for sure
maybe it would be a little more legit
than us just like holding our phone over
the mic
i don't know it just feels like one of
those times where you're a little like
homesick for your friends and family you
know yeah it's been a significant amount
of time and
i don't know it just always makes me
feel a little better to talk to some of
my friends or
family or something so i hope you guys
are doing the same and keeping in touch
and um you know
taking care of each other yeah yeah i
don't know some like
facetiming a family member or a friend
right now might seem like
you don't really want to do it but i
feel like once you try it once you do it
it's actually kind of incredible like
what that can do for you
unless you're doing it too much and then
you're just [ __ ] annoyed
yeah i see people complaining about
their like zoom
calls are like getting really annoying
like then maybe you should take a break
from your friends and family
yeah but it's fun to connect and uh it's
we're super fortunate to be able to like
live in a right
time to be able to just like pick up
your phone and be with somebody well
what's crazy is like when i was a little
kid
uh my grandparents or like aunts and
uncles or anybody that didn't see me
every day
like they would see pictures of me and i
would talk to them on the phone
but like they didn't watch me like grow
you know and i think it's just so cool
to you know
not necessarily have to miss each
other's lives just because we can't be
physically in them
yeah for sure super special uh
anyway thank you guys for listening and
hanging out with us and if you found
this
entertaining and fun i hope you did if
you did thank you very much
you enjoyed the the sushi shirt
appearance
and the list and the jokes from chris
melberger always love those
uh but if you guys want us to do more of
this or this in a different way or
whatever let us know in the comments or
any other ideas you have in the comments
because
man we don't even know what the [ __ ] to
do anymore we're just like
we're just trying to make it through and
make content but
it is definitely sort of hard sometimes
but uh we appreciate you guys being here
and watching and listening and hanging
out with us and we hope you guys have a
good week and stay safe
hell yeah and we'll see you on the next
podcast bye
[Music]